we are learning new details on the  arrest of a  babysitter for killing a five-year-old  boy lauren courtney facing charges for  first degree murder in  eight counts for child abuse the arrest  report showing courtney was watching  ryan perelto and his sibling when  she called his parents to say ryan was  coughing up blood  the father came home to find his son  unresponsive  he later watched surveillance video from  inside his home showing courtney  kicking hitting and dragging his son  courtney told police she heard ryan  fall in the shower but she may have  blacked out after being  frustrated that he apparently had  urinated on himself courtney's next  court date  is scheduled for the 18th of may